welcome everybody to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee a little bit
of housekeeping first if the fire alarm
is activated please take the stairs down
to the reception area and out of the
building to the green in hawley square
which is the assembly point
please do not use the lifts officers
will assist you and advise you when it
is deemed safe to return to the council
offices
i don't think there's any apologies for
absence
and debt agenda item two declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest
now we're going to agenda item 3
application for a new premises license
at staples stores
19 sit mildred's walk west gate on sea
i call upon miss phillips the council's
principal litigation solicitor to
explain to the parties procedure that we
will be taking during this hearing
thank you very much
good morning i'd just like to everyone
to know that the decisions that are made
by the subcommittee today that they're
made in accordance with the license in
act 2003 and it's based on the
information that's been presented in
this agenda with any verbal submissions
that's made today
um the decisions aren't politically
based um the subcommittee will act
impartially and offer a fair and
unbiased hearing of the application
as was said we're here to consider the
application for new premises
license
at staples stores 19 cent mildred's walk
westgate
on sea
um the application is being made by
steven gad for new premises license and
we will hear the parties in the
following order we'll hear the licensing
officer
and then we'll hear the applicant for
the license
we'll hear
any representative you may have
and
the representations that's made by the
objectors
and each party has
up to around 15 minutes to make
a presentation
and um but you're not required to speak
for 15 minutes
and following each presentation members
of the subcommittee may ask questions
and
the licensing officer may ask questions
and equally you may ask questions to the
licensing officer and any other person
who makes
representations also
at the end of the proceedings each party
will have five minutes to make a closing
statement
um in the same order
and
the meeting will then adjourn for the
subcommittee to consider its decision
and
when we adjourn the subcommittee members
the legal officer
and the clerk will remain in the council
chamber
to
deliberate
for about maybe 30 minutes and then
we'll resume for the decision to be read
out by myself thank you
thank you thank you miss phillips i
would like to stress the importance of
following this hearing procedure and
that there will be an opportunity for
all parties to make a final presentation
after questioning
therefore i would advise all present to
please follow the procedure and to
respect those speaking by not
interrupting or speaking over others
if people do interrupt or speak over
others
would the technical team support please
present their
report
morning everyone um
you know we're here to look at an
application for a premises license
staple stores the builders walk west
gate
the original
license the original application came in
in june last year and was advertised
and at that time
we got some representations came through
then and the hours that were applied for
were
at that time they were 11 o'clock close
with half past 10 for alcohol
um the license was put on hold because
there's some issues to do with planning
the premises basically has been renamed
as it should be 19th mildred's walk and
not submilled as road as it was
previously
and when the planning was dealt with the
applicant obviously took
notice of the objections that had been
received the first for when it was first
originally put up
and so he reduced his hours to seven
o'clock with a six 30 6 30 for our car
seven o'clock closing so those hours are
now set in planning and that means that
the applicant or anybody else who should
take on that premises cannot operate out
of those hours unless they go through
new planning permission
so um there's no representations from
the police or any of the other
responsible authorities so um over to
you to
listen to everything and make your
decision
thank you
um mr gerd and miss young would you
present your case please
um yeah
just to reiterate what allison said yeah
we originally put it in last summer we
had problems with the planning
and then speaking with alison and also
the environmental health we then reduced
the hours
the main reason really why we want to
put this application in is is only just
to drive some revenue
we all know the situation globally
that's not we don't need to be that drum
it's hard you know it's hard at the
moment and we're just looking for an
extra revenue stream
um to to bring in some some some more
some some extra cash
and the actual premises you know we took
over a pretty dilapidated building if
i'm honest with you and we've spent you
know
money time and energy bringing it up to
you know a nice spec and nothing is
brought it's definitely brought the area
up we've installed you know color cctv
and we've put fences in we've got an
alarm system
that the cctv that actual corner where
we are there's no doubt that it's more
secure there's no doubt it's more secure
for us being there
and i and i don't and i think as well
it's just about looking small businesses
i'm a chef by trade i do run a bakery
i've kind of fallen into that through
kovid and just kind of it's kind of
you know we've done well we've opened
the second shop and it's just about
ideally what i wanted to do we've
shortened the hours on a friday and
thursday afternoon from when we closed
the bakery so from two till six in the
evening to have a few small plates where
that's plates of cheese plated
charcuterie and a nice alcohol offer um
and then also as well it does give us um
the chance if someone phones up and says
look could we have a party or a passer
you know not a party party like a
uh a baby shower or a private function
that we have the ability to offer them
cooked you know cooked food or platters
as well as alcohol alcohol does bring in
money and it does make money um
i'm a chef by trade and i like the idea
of that and just to note we have had two
sunday roasts there which we we spoke
with alliance and everyone bought byo
and everything that was highlighted in
the objections
it didn't come to fruition at all we
attracted a lovely demographic of people
um we've had no complaints from anyone
as we've no place from the police to the
to the licensing officer and i think the
main we don't want to upset the
neighbours right we we we live we live
and work together i'm not coming i think
it's very reasonable and i even we spoke
to the environmental health and it kind
of went back and forth and we both
agreed that
you know seven o'clock in the evening to
leave is is super reasonable you know it
means that i can't open for dinner you
know i can't do an evening service as
such i can only operate between two and
six now really two and six isn't the
ideal time but you know that's what
keeps the peace and that's what keeps
everyone happy then so be it i'll work
around that and then also going forward
once we're a bit more established to
offer you know if we can do a sunday
roast and have a nice glass of wine with
it
that's that it's never going to turn
into a bar i'm a fat i'm a father of
three family of three there's so three
children i don't want to turn into a bar
i'm not interested in running a bar
there's not going to be taps there's not
going to be you know
bar stools
and fruit machines and anything that is
associated with the objections we all
know that type of establishment the
licensing that knows that as well we're
not going to be that we're going to have
bottles of beer we're going to be we're
going to have a selection of natural
craft wines that are selected which
again which is the biggest circle at the
moment of supporting local suppliers
supporting local distributors supporting
you know smaller producers of wine and
beer which again they need to be
supported this isn't
i'm not going to have pints of carlsberg
and gross and stellar on tap it's not
going to be that it's not going to be
shots or anything like that it's going
to be well sourced and well executed
alcohol range as well as the food
how many times a year i'm going to do
this i don't know you know i don't think
it's going to be a regular weekly thing
i don't think it's going to be a monthly
thing it's when we can do it i mean i've
commonly worked seven day a week so the
idea to do but it'd be good to have
to be good to have to to you know if the
opportunity does if the phone rings
tomorrow and someone says steve you know
i want to have
a baby shower or
there's
12 of us meeting could you do some
charcuterie and a couple of bottles of
wine great it's just an extra revenue
stream and i just want to say on the
objections i think the idea that i just
want to highlight this because it is the
idea that children wouldn't feel safe in
their garden and
extra drug activity around the
establishment as well as urinating i'm
not too sure what kind of establishment
they think it's going to be but i can
assure you
that is just not going to happen in any
sense i've got three children we get the
police have been down twice we're two
different plays they've changed both
please so when we first applied
and the second they've changed please
both police officers there's been no
complaints there's no worries whatsoever
not even equivalent about
the the objections that came up right
they just said okay this is fine as long
as half six as long as we've got the
right you know the papers up and the
monthly cctv there's some
guidance but there's been no problems
and if there was a problem you know we
wouldn't probably we won't be sat here
you know we're not looking to upset the
local neighbours we've really not i've
had enough drama with redding street my
other shop and now the neighbors are
back on side because they understand
that you know it's a it's just it's two
people running a small business looking
after three children
trying to make ends meet let's be honest
this isn't a sob story this is the
reality of small businesses it's hard
work and i don't want to create
any more work for councillors or
licensing department or the police or
any kind of services that doesn't need
to be and i and i think the you know and
i think what we've put in is very
sensible and i think we manage it
correctly and if there is any problems
then i'm there all the time you can you
know we can mitigate it and we can work
it out and
i'll talk for england so i'll just leave
it at that i just think it's a set i
think we i think the the the i'll end on
when we originally applied probably a
bit too accessory of the hours
talking to allison and the environmental
health we've reduced the hours and
and and i honestly think the objections
are a
in some cases ridiculously um a bit wild
and i think staples stores has been
um has been has made a positive impact
in the area as well as the location of
where it is
because the location isn't a back alley
it's a little bit fruity down there with
some of the people who live at the top
but
with the cameras that we've got with our
hours that we're open i definitely think
it's be it's an asset to the community
and that's all i've got to say thank you
thank you
um
that was very well
spoken miss young do you want to add
anything are you happy with that
okay does the licensing team have any
questions for mr guide and miss youngs
does your premises actually see how many
will you have any draft beer or is it
all just casts
no
any spirits or is it just literally wine
and ciders and bottles there might be
some spirits there might be some
pre-made cocktails so the kind of the
ready-made i mean like negroni's
margaritas that kind of thing it won't
be like
you know the sex on the beach probably
that kind of stuff it would just be
the classic ones
no more questions no
now members of the public making
representations may ask the applicant's
question
this is not the point in the meeting to
state your case or opinions this will
come later so please stick to it just
any questions if you do not have any
questions please say no questions mr
patrick do you have any questions for
miss gad or miss young
um why was redding street did does that
have an alcohol license did he apply for
an alcohol license and
yes
yeah to mr gad
uh
did he did he have any complaints from
the neighbors
that's fine
so
sorry we don't do we have a mr docherty
mrs dougherty you'd look nothing like a
mister
sorry
i that was my query when you arrived
so
mrs patrick do you have any questions
for mr gad or miss young
um i don't but i'm going to say cover it
all in my presentation okay
uh do members of the committee have any
questions for mr gad on this young
[Applause]
covered everything i was gonna ask yep
this is the point of the meeting at
which members of the public making
representations will get to present
their case
uh mrs patrick please can you make your
representation
oh mrs dockety no i've got sorry mr mr
pence sorry can you make your
representation understand that you're
also speaking on behalf of miss mears
uh 40 homes surround staples stores we
live just meters away from the stores so
we feel would be affected
there is some doubt about the public
right away of the alley it's very bumpy
you know the council don't seem to want
to take responsibility
so we're worried that when people have
had a drink walking down that alley
you know
whose responsibility is it if they if
they have a fall
we don't want to stop mr gad earning any
money but not at our expense the alley
is very quiet
and there has never been a problem in
the alley as far as i know i know he's
put cctv up and lighting i think that's
for his own use really you know to
protect his building not you know not
our homes
um
the other point is
most of the houses there have garages if
with me
and
if we want to put garages in our homes
in our gardens
our cars will come just meters away
from the front door of staples stores if
i drive my car out
it will only be a metre maybe a meter
and a half away
so everybody else has garages i could
you know apply for that
and
um
that's about it really i just think that
we don't have a problem with it being a
baker's we have a problem with the
alcohol license really you know we're
it's a residential area there is 40
homes around there and you know just me
is away so we'd like to
stop the alcohol license
can you just turn off your
thank you
is that are you making another
representation on behalf of
okay
uh mrs dougherty can you please make
your representation yes first of all i'd
like to say i totally understand your
situation of uh it's very hard in small
businesses these days
and i would first like to say that i'm
happy i'm going to read it because i
it's
clearer for me um i'd first like to say
that i'm happy that there's a bakery in
saint mildred's walk with great products
that not only i have enjoyed but members
of my family extended family friends and
colleagues have enjoyed as well
fabulous i also understand the concept
of this sort of bistro bakery as an
attractive business
also over the years we've had no problem
with all the other businesses that were
previously on this premises
and those who are present working within
this area
my house backs directly onto the bakery
so it's about from my back gate one
meter away so i mean it's great in the
morning you can just open the gate and
come and get their lovely sourdough
bread
um but i do want to exercise my um right
to be able to
express myself on my opposition
unfortunately regarding this alcohol
license for staples
under the prevention of public nuisance
laws the main issue
is that the bakery is in a courtyard i
know this has been expressed in
everybody said this but i want to
reiterate this where approximately
40 to 50 apartments and some house
houses which includes mine
back onto and overlook the bakery
noise resonates very easily in this area
most of the rooms overlooking the
courtyard are bedrooms where some of the
occupants including my husband work in
the service industry
and some in the health industry and work
on shift over the years everyone has
been extremely respectful including the
bakery up till now
to each other regarding noise and
disturbance in the evening
we are generally a kind and tolerant
neighborhood
also the businesses that are at present
in this area
and were previously there all respected
the privacy and respect for each
neighbor
the serving of alcohol and alcohol
related issues could produce disturbance
due to drunken disorderly behavior
in a residential and respectful
neighborly environment
if this alcohol license is granted to
staples a big concern would be if the
bakery would beat it were to be sold and
change is made
turning the uh business into a bar or
brewery or if the bakery themselves
although he has mr gad has stipulated
that
he doesn't plan on doing it turn it into
a bar eventually
so from experience this could cause a
good deal of disturbance linked to
alcohol related issues so i'll give an
example
so for us in ethelbert square so the
other side of my house we had a
workmen's club which functioned for many
years quite peacefully and we were okay
with it it was then sold on where there
was a lot of disturbance for the
residents including so my sitting room
overlooks the park
including drug dealing to the customers
it wasn't the bar as such but they were
waiting outside
selling drugs in the darker part of the
park opposite our houses and in the core
darker corners of saint mildred's walk
at the first part
i know this won't happen if it's a seven
o'clock thing but the new request for a
license until 7 pm
was previously a request for 11 pm
this gives us no guarantee in the
neighborhood that the goal post will
change once again in the future
allowing this present request for a
license to be pushed from 7 to 11 or
whoever it's sold onto
maybe regarding public safety i would
like to draw attention to the traffic in
st mildred's walk this is an area used
mainly by delivery trucks loading and
unloading for businesses on the high
street
and for the delivery service for the
medication stored at the back of paden's
the chemist which is directly next door
to the bakery staples
overall movement of cars is not constant
but can occur in waves and could cause
public safety problems in a narrow and
badly lit area
i feel i've covered the main issues here
and have expressed valid concerns for
myself and the neighborhood regarding
this matter
okay
thank you
did the licensing team have any
questions for mr patrick or mrs dockerty
i
i'd just like to state where um
this seven o'clock hours are set in
planning
so planning takes precedence over
licensing
so we could not increase hours for that
premises unless a planning application
was put in and if a planning application
is put in that is when you would have
chance to say something because you
would all be notified that a planning
application has gone in
it was the license
and with discussions with planning it
was a great and environmental health it
was agreed to pull it back to seven
o'clock it has to shut at seven o'clock
so you could apply again
it would have to go via planning first
it cannot come to licensing to have the
hours increased it would have to go via
planning first
could i
could i
reply
um
uh
i i fully understand that but the the
problem is it could be a bit of a
pandora's box
so initially it starts like that and
then the thing sort of develops onto
other things if the business is sold on
so that's our main concern
i know mr gatt has
invested a lot of um
money in his business and i i appreciate
that but we too in our homes
um and our gardens and our environment
um so just want to take note of that
okay sorry
mr gad and miss young have you any
questions
uh mr patrick mr
to the like do the members of the
committee have any questions
just one question you mentioned
deliveries around the back and you
mentioned the chemist paid-ins so what
time is their delivery
i don't really monitor
the times but i know that at times we
have an auction house that's open so
people come to collect things from the
auction house
or uh
things are delivered to pay i don't know
the times of that but they do have a
delivery service where they take
medication to the public
so there is movement it's not sorry it's
not constant
but there there is movement um and to
maneuver it's quite difficult around
there depending on the size of the
vehicle of course
so are you saying that having a license
will stop deliveries being picked up
no that's more
on a public safety issue if you have
families with for example
young children and they're not paying
attention and
you know it's sort of an awkward area
okay
any more questions from the committee
thank you i would now like to ask each
party to sum up and make final
representations
uh mr patrick can you make your final
comments
i think i've covered everything
mr garden miss young do you have any
would you like to sum up at all
um no just to say that i hope if it goes
either way that we can we can be
agreeable on it and and i think if it
does get past either it does it doesn't
i would
i don't i'm not in the business to upset
to upset people and also on selling the
business really
you know that's something that is out of
our hands and i can't you know we could
i don't think the worry can be on that
and also the one thing i would say is
our landlords are very they're friends
of ours they're very respectable as well
um they're local people and i think they
would also make a call on who they'd
sell the business to so i would just say
that the truck that the trust has to be
in us and the landlords that we would be
respectful
thank you
thank you very much
with the exception of the board members
the democratic service officer and the
legal officer can i please ask all those
presents to leave so that the board can
come to a decision
you will be invited back into the room
for the decision to be announced
[Applause]
you
thank you very much i would now like to
invite ms phillips a principal
litigation solicitor to read a summary
of the subcommittee's determination
thank you
in the application for new premises
license at staples stores 19 saint
mildred's walk westgate on c kent made
to thana district council as the
relevant licensing authority in
accordance with the licensing act and
upon consideration of the
representations made by the licensing
authority um the applicant and the the
representations um
from mr patrick and mr dockerty um the
subcommittee did consider everything
that was said
against the licensing objectives against
the
particulars of the licensing act
and but it is the decision of the
licensing committee to grant the
application today
thank you all very much for your time
today
meeting concluded at 10 35.
you